[Music]
the question is where do we go from here
where would neuroscience advance from
here to understanding the kind of things
that I think personally are unique to
human beings so let's have a thought
experiment suppose in a hundred years
time we have a complete readout of the
total neural activity of someone who's
been in love for three months and we
also have a complete description of the
connectome a projects going on in the EU
at the moment two million quid you know
how the brain is wired up etc etc what
would be the result of that well one
result would be billions and billions of
noughts and zeros indicating in euros
off or in earns on do you think you
would understand anything more about
what it's like to be in love what it's
likely wise or foolish and so on and the
answer is no so clearly it's not as if
we're going to make much progress -
assuming these slightly higher order
things from perception onwards by brain
science one final point in relation to
perception the great Hubel and Wiesel
who were the great neurophysiologists of
perception won the Nobel Prize they
ended their lives I forgot which one of
what was saying essentially we don't
understand how edge perception and color
and the sense of distance and so on all
come together in the same spot for me to
be able to see that is my cup over there
so we don't even understand the
beginning of understanding how we unify
neural activity or putative neural
activity into a perception of an object
out there and that's because there is no
way that neuroscience can handle
intentionality which is absolute
fundamental to mind above the level of
pure sensation so Ray's touched on the
binding problem I think they're putting
it all together but I wonder whether
Susanna you can think of examples too to
offer array where we talk about why
there would be some surprises things
that we have in a common sense way
thought about vision or thought about
our senses actually get revised when we
find out how things are actually working
I wanted to address four stuff that a
human whistle did not and
Thorsten we shall he still alive they
thought and I I did I did trying with
David Hubel and to the rest of my
knowledge he never said you know I give
up
who knows what's happening we can get a
handle on it on the contrary he and
Torsten Wiesel develop functional
architecture and they brought structure
and function together and sure they were
a word that we had not solved the visual
system but their self quite a bit of the
early stages and I think they made a
major contribution and neuroscience is
not finished but I think that and it may
be that we don't have the methods it may
be that we need to reconsider a lot of
the foundational basis but but there's
been a large amount of very significant
progress that has been made and I would
I would also want to address the the
issue of love and understanding what's
happening in the brain when somebody's
in love to be sure we're not there but
that doesn't mean that he's not
achievable and if we didn't understand
exactly what it means that from a neural
basis to be in love I think that it
would be much easier to come up with
very practical applications like maybe
see people want to fall in love or they
want to fall out of love and if we
understand how the brain is doing that
they may be a lot of people that will be
interested in gaining some access to the
neural processes and that are in have
very real applications for more debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the Institute of Arts and ideas at III
TV
you